[Music]
hey you guys welcome to my tomes of
terror series
uh this is where i'm gonna be reviewing
horror books old ones new ones whichever
ones i happen to feel like reviewing
so let's get started so when i was first
doing the you know kind of background
and like deciding to do
this series on the 13 o'clock show
was basically i want to get back into
reading horror fiction because i used to
read a lot of it and then for the past
few years i kind of got more into
nonfiction and i kind of got behind on a
lot of the newer authors and whatnot
so when i was so one of the goals was
you know i really wanted to get a good
feel of what was out there what was
being recommended by other channels like
you know what was well reviewed and
stuff because there's a really really
lot of
horror fiction out there as most people
know um especially with the advent of
self-publishing
and i didn't really want to spend a lot
of time like wading through like
thousands and thousands of books and
like looking for something good and you
know having to go through stuff that
maybe wasn't so great
so i kind of started going through all
the goodreads lists like the best rated
horror stuff and you know started
subscribing to a lot of other like
horror
booktubers like you know book reviewers
and seeing what they recommended
so i was able to get like a pretty good
um you know core
list of like the same authors that kept
coming up the same books that kept
getting recommended
so that was kind of what i started out
as doing
now one of the authors that probably
came up
you know very often like one of the most
often
in a lot of these different lists and
shows that i was watching
was anya alborn now she is apparently
like from what i know about i don't know
a great deal about her but um i guess
she was born in poland and she lives in
south carolina now
um her first book was called seed and
she self-published it
and it ended up um being like the number
one
horror book on amazon and she
subsequently
got a contract with simon schuster i
believe which has published some of her
like kind of bigger books
and um you know so she's kind of very
well known in the horror community
now that said um i hadn't read any of
her stuff so i wanted to
kind of get started with you know
reading all of her
work so i wasn't really sure where to
start now i do
i'm gonna say like right out of the gate
i do prefer to have
physical copies of the books that i'm
going to review and i do actually have
physical copies of a lot of the ones
that i'm going to review and i've
ordered a lot of them as well so i can
you know kind of show them on the show
because i just
i prefer to read actual paper books i
know that's weird but um
and i like to be able to like show them
on the show but this one
um was actually on because i have a
kindle unlimited subscription
so this one of her books was available
uh for free as kindle unlimited
so i decided to start with this one so i
read the ebook version
which means that um you know i don't
have a book to show you so
you know i'll just put it i'll put it
like over there over there
wherever i don't know where i'm gonna
put it this book is called
if you see her now this came out in 2019
and even though i guess that she has
like i said you know a contract with
simon and schuster who have published
like some of her better known books
this one i believe she published on her
own
now she says in the back of the book
that this one like she kind of got
started on it and then i guess she had a
baby and like so obviously she didn't
have a lot of time to finish a book
um so finally she got it done and i
guess she felt like she wanted to put it
out on her own
so that's kind of what ended up
happening so this is actually one of her
more
recent books i don't think it's her
newest one because i think she had one
out this year maybe
but um it is one of her more recent ones
so i decided that this would be a good
one to start with and you know the
synopsis sounded kind of cool so the
synopsis of this one
this basically follows a guy named jesse
wells
and he lives in this little like
[ __ ] nowhere town
uh called warsaw michigan and um you
know he's one of those guys where
you know he wants to be a writer and
he's like you know
i guess i don't want to say like smarter
than anybody else in town but he kind of
like has larger ambitions
from this little town and wants to get
the hell out of there now
the book starts in i believe 2000 or
2001
when uh jesse and his two friends whose
names are casey and reed
they're in high school or they're
getting ready to graduate from high
school
and what ends up happening is that i
guess there's this creepy old house
um like sort of out beyond the edges of
the town
and it kind of has all these reputation
like you know about um you know suicides
murders like all kind of
you know ghost stories and [ __ ] like
that about it you're just your typical
like haunted house type of thing out at
the edge of town
so they um decide that
they're gonna like have a few drinks and
they're gonna drive
out there uh you know just to kind of
hang out or whatever now
it comes to pass that jesse
has had a bad experience there when he
was a kid i believe he was 11 years old
and i don't think he told the other guys
about it um
but i guess reed who's the guy that's
driving out on this excursion
he's kind of become obsessed with this
house since like all he does is like
think about it and talk about it and
sometimes he goes and drives and like
sits in front of it in his car and
everything
so so they're driving out there and
jesse is like really not happy about it
because he didn't know that that's where
they were going to be going
so they end up going to the house and
you know it's this is going to have
light spoilers i'm not
really gonna spoil anything that wasn't
uh
you know in the description of the book
that was like on goodreads and stuff
like that but
if i do actually happen to spoil things
i've you know i'm sorry about that but
i'm just saying it's probably mild
spoilers i'm not gonna tell you the end
or anything
um which will probably be par for the
course with all the book reviews because
it's hard to talk about them if you
can't talk about what happened in the
book
to a certain extent so if you want to
come at things
like just completely blind then you know
you might want to turn this off and
come back to it later like after you've
read the book so
they end up going out to the house um
casey and reed
go up because casey is like a
photographer and he's like fascinated
with abandoned
buildings and whatnot so they go inside
the house but jesse kind of chickens out
and he stays outside
now when they go in there it turns out
that reed
goes up to like the fourth floor of the
mansion and
apparently jumps off or commits suicide
at least that's the story
so that's kind of like a traumatic thing
that happened
like in the past so then we come forward
to 2019
where you know jesse is the main
character and casey are all grown up
jesse has uh not been able to
um realize his dream of becoming a
writer and he's working as an english
teacher
in the same high school that he
graduated from in the same small town
and he's kind of not happy about it uh
he did marry his
uh you know high school sweetheart or
whatever which he's happy about that and
they've just had a son
but he's kind of like bummed out that
he's still stuck in this town and he's
you know he was going to be the next
stephen king he said and it's like he
never really got anywhere he never
finished a novel he never did anything
like that
so when you get when we go forward to
the present
then casey the other guy that was like
his friend that was there when reed
supposedly committed suicide
he comes back to the house and he's been
like acting
he's acting really weird and he
basically says to jesse okay well we
have to go back to that house
um to kind of get closure you know and
he's just acting really bizarre and
jesse doesn't want to go
obviously but he does end up going
much to his detriment let's uh say that
and that's probably as much of the plot
as i'm going to give away
now what i will say about this book
is that it's a really i read it in like
two days because it was one of those
things where like when i was reading it
i was like yeah this is like pretty good
and stuff like that but then when i
wasn't reading it i kept thinking about
it like man i should
get back to that because i wanted to see
what would happen so
she does have a really good way of
getting the story moving getting you
invested in it like
really quickly and getting you to really
just
want to keep reading it you know i mean
it's like you did i didn't really want
to put it down
and i finished it really really quickly
um
i will say too that this is it gave me i
don't know if all of her books are like
this because this is the first one of
hers that i've
read i'm going to review some other ones
too because i actually do have a print
version of one of her books
that i'm going to review eventually so i
don't know if all of them are like that
it's very it's
stephen king i guess not as like
gory or like oh because i don't want to
say like over the top but it's not
it's a little more like low-key than
stephen king i guess so it's like kind
of like
low-key stephen king and particularly
the main character
in this book if you see her jesse wells
he reminded me very much of jack torren
it's not from the movie but from the
novel
in the sense that he was you know
in a teacher who was aspiring to be a
writer but was kind of like perceived
himself as a failure
um he was also an alcoholic um at some
point like when he was younger but had
been sober for a very long time but it
was still something that was
haunting him and he still had like a lot
of demons and stuff
and in this story as it goes on and he
starts to become
obsessed with what's going on in this
house and having visions about what's
going on in this house and
kind of developing this obsession where
he has to like write about it
and what he thinks happened there
because he starts having visions about
this little girl
and um that's really scary and he just
like wants to get to the bottom of the
mystery of like what happened there even
though he thinks he's making it up and
there's like all this other stuff going
on or you know and you don't know if
it's like
just all him making it up or if it's
like something that actually happened
there that he's like tapping into how
somehow
but as it goes on and as he becomes more
you know tied up with this house and
like obsessed with his novel
he goes he starts going very much like
jack torrance's character where he
starts like descending into madness he
starts like
getting really self-destructive he
starts like
lashing out at people around him like
his wife and uh you know
his friends and things and so it it gave
me that kind of vibe like big time and
also
the kind of um it's you know it's not
quite as sprawling as like a stephen
king story because stephen king tends to
like have like a whole bunch of
characters
uh whereas this one was very much just
focused on uh jesse wells and you're
in his head most of the time um you know
there's other characters that are
important but he's kind of the main one
and you're
you're seeing everything from his point
of view um
i will say and i and i saw this in a lot
of other reviews of this book that the
main character
of jesse wells was kind of unlikable or
was hard to root for
i didn't find him particularly unlikable
you know and i didn't have a problem
like relating to him
although i will say that he was a
frustrating character but i think he was
meant to be a frustrating character i
mean he had his own
demons with alcoholism he had his own
demons of
you know just feeling like a failure in
life and trying to find like writing
inspiration
and not really being able to do it he
you know yes he was
depressive yes he was you know sometimes
he should have asked for help or he
should have told
his wife or his friends or something
like that what was going on rather than
keeping everything to himself
um but it didn't bother me that much
because
you know even though it's frustrating in
terms of the story
it very much was in accordance with his
character
because that's very much what he was
like he didn't want to ask for help he
wanted to be able to
sort things out on his own and not
burden other people maybe so so i didn't
really find that
a problem and like i said i didn't find
him particularly unlikable although i
can see how
some readers might um this also gave me
a little bit
of uh an exercise excercisty kind of
vibe too
and like because there's some kind of
demon possession kind of stuff going on
which i liked but you know it's not
super original
like i said this is this is basically a
haunted house
demon possession ghost kind of story and
like descendant of madness kind of story
so it's like stephen king
sort of shining ye with some exorcisty
kind of vibe to it
but not as like overtly
crazy it's more like creepy more dread
inducing more
it's not like overtly horror there's
like some action in it there's you know
stuff like that but
it's not kind of like these big action
set pieces and it's very much focused on
just this
main character and a couple of other uh
you know characters around him
which actually i kind of like um i liked
it better that was kind of a more
intimate
story now just from a very nitpicky
because i'm really anal retentive about
grammar
uh if you know me you will know this i
you know i don't know like if she had an
outside editor on this one or whatever
but there was a couple of typos in this
which that's not a big deal like a typo
but one thing that bothered me that
probably wasn't a typo because it
happened at least four or five times
was that she would write that somebody
had lied when they met when she met like
had lay
you know what i mean like the where the
body had lay
uh she would say where the body had lied
and she did that like
a cup a few times and it always kind of
like maybe go
wait what so it always kind of like drew
me out of the story which is really
weird because
you know everywhere else like the
english is like perfectly
cromulent it was you know it was like
perfectly fine but then
there was just that and it happened like
more than once so it really really
bugged me because i was like had lied
did you like read that out loud it's
like that's not how dear swiss is it was
you know
so that kind of bothered me a little bit
too but like i said that's very very
very nitpicky
um i will say that the ending of this
was very
um bleak which i dig that i like that
you know i if it can have a happy ending
too i don't really care it's as long as
it kind of makes sense in the course of
the story
but i'm not gonna like be all like one
of those people that is like oh i don't
like bleak endings or
anything like that because um i don't
mind them at all
and i think in the context of this story
um i think it might have been like the
only
possible ending um you know with the
mythology that she had constructed
because what you know before it ended i
was sitting there thinking well i don't
know how you're gonna
fix this you know what i mean like i
didn't know how he's gonna fix it so i
kind of like that now
from what i've heard like i said this is
the first book of hers that i've read
um but i've had her have heard other
people talking about her books that she
um often does do rather bleak endings so
just you know
fyi if you're not into bleak endings and
you don't
everything has to have a happy ending or
whatever also if you don't really want
to read
about uh multiple suicides if you don't
really want to read about
like a really depressed um character
who's just kind of smiling
spiraling into like obsession and
madness and violence and
things like that then this might not be
for you but
overall um i really enjoyed this book
like i said it's
you know it's not a super original idea
but
i dug it i i mean i dug it enough to
like read it in two days because
you know i just kept even when i was
working on other things my like my mind
kept wandering back it's like man i
really
need to get back to that and like read a
couple more chapters and see what's
going to happen
so i you know so that's good if i had to
give it a star rating which i probably i
don't really want to get into the
into the habit of doing that because
it's i don't know star ratings just
seemed very reductive
but if i had to give it a star rating
i'd probably give it like maybe three
and a half out of five
um you know what i mean just a really
good quick read if you're really into
like supernatural uh you know small town
haunted house
demon possession type of horror um
you'll probably dig it like i said
this is only the first one of her books
that i've read and i definitely plan to
read other ones
um i have one as a matter of fact like
in that pile right there which i'm going
to get to
eventually so it's uh if you have a
kindle unlimited subscription
it is available to read for free on
there right now so uh if you want you
can
check it out and i'll see you next time
bye